the CDC reports there are now more than
ten times as many confirmed measles
cases in 2019
as there were in all of 2010 think about
that for a second the vast majority of
infections are among unvaccinated people
our doctor Jon LaPook was at the New
York State Capitol yesterday where
protesters including a member of the
Kennedy family gathered to fight a bill
to end religious exemptions for vaccines
dr. Luke has been looking into where
some of this myths information is coming
from John there's a lot of intense
feelings on both sides of this issue
that's for sure Hill yeah
good morning yesterday we told you about
an organization targeting ultra-orthodox
Jewish communities with vaccine
misinformation a few hours later we went
to a rally held by vaccine opponents
including Robert F Kennedy jr. and at
times it was testy
the reason they call you auntie boxers
it manufactured is it so
Robert F Kennedy jr. spoke to a crowd of
around 250 people on Tuesday after his
speech we pulled him aside last week two
of Kennedy's siblings and a niece
slammed him for his stance on vaccines
they accused him of putting children at
risk and said his work is having
heartbreaking consequences the CDC says
there are currently more than 800 cases
of measles in the United States the
measles vaccine was introduced in 1963
and by 2000 the virus was considered
eliminated here how many people this
room do not believe that the information
coming from the Centers of Disease
Control is correct about that
we were there as some of the protesters
met a legislator when we asked them
questions
it sometimes got fiery so you're not
worried about the kid who is not realize
to us all the time at Tuesday's rally we
caught up with del big tree one of the
most well known and outspoken opponents
of vaccines are you getting any funding
you personally from any outside source
sure I have a non-profit we took a look
at the 2017 tax filings for big trees
nonprofit and found in one year his
contributions went from just over a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars to
more than 1.4 million multiple different
donors or what is there one biggest one
multiple different donors you have a
main one who is the biggest donor big
tree says his donors are funding new
laws and helping him fight legal battles
and they include doctors and celebrities
who were marveling does he have to
disclose who his donors are you know I
asked him who are they specifically and
who's the biggest one he said well I
don't get into all of that so we clearly
didn't want to answer the question but
we were marveling about your story
yesterday John what's your big takeaway
after all of them you know Gail it's
very complicated obviously but one thing
is I think we have to find some answers
not complicate the science is not but
there's common ground and the common
ground is we all love our kids we would
do anything for our kids we all want
them to be healthy I spoke with a lot of
the protesters yesterday they love their
kids but there's also fear belief and
misinformation that's a tough concoction
right so we know it doesn't work it
doesn't work to yell at them to be
condescending I think you have to
address it with empathy with softness
with a dialogue conversation and with
science and at the end of the day
realize you're not going to win over
everybody but I think that's the best
path but what's what's the response when
people don't believe the science and the
facts you know that's what is so what so
that's but you know we found in this CBS
Sunday morning piece that we did on
Sunday well there's a place in the north
western oregon called boost and there's
dr. Joel and he spends 2-3 hours he's a
pediatrician explaining to hesitant
parents vaccine has been parents
answering all of their questions what
are your specific concerns and you know
what
says he says 99% of the time he's able
to get them to do the vaccines so I
don't think that most of the people are
these died in the wolves we're never
gonna do it they're scared they love
their kids they're fearful a lot of them
have kids or know somebody who had an
injury following a vaccine they link the
two together and there's no way to get
rid of that belief belief is such a
powerful thing thank you John thank you
John